companies say that efficiency and
productivity gains are two of the most
significant benefits of implementing AI
within the Enterprise no wonder the
artificial intelligence Market is
expected to grow from 58.3 billion US
dollars in 2021 to
309.6 billion by 2026 at a cagr of 39.7
percent
so how can one join the AI bandwagon
hello and welcome to simplylearn's
artificial intelligence engineer
master's program in collaboration with
IBM which prepares you to Pioneer the
next generation of AI the role of an AI
engineer is constantly Reinventing
itself previously companies would hire
individuals with different areas of
expertise like data scientists data
engineers and machine learning Engineers
these people would then work in
different teams to build and deploy a
scalable AI application
however many AI driven companies now
realize that these roles are highly
intertwined they need individuals
skilled in all three and can come up
with AI solutions that can be deployed
and scaled no wonder companies are
paying skilled AI experts over
114k per annum is our artificial
intelligence engineer master's program
the right choice for you ranked number
one best AI course by career Karma our
artificial intelligence engineer
master's program is offered in
collaboration with IBM and transforms
you into an AI engineer fully capable of
planning and executing AI initiatives in
your organization however to excel it is
necessary to understand particular math
and statistics principles along with
knowledge of at least one programming
language data structured and logic
what makes this program different our
master's programs are precisely role
alive and help develop skills for real
career growth with three Capstone and 12
industry relevant projects you'll also
get Hands-On training using multiple
industry standard tools professional
swear by
other key benefits of the program learn
from industry experts work on industry
relevant problems get 24 7 learning
support learn with live virtual sessions
simply learns job assist service helps
you get noticed by top hiring companies
don't miss out on a great career
opportunity join the artificial
intelligence engineer master's program
today
foreign
[Music]